(light music)
- I'm Stephen Wiltshire.
I do drawings.
- [Narrator] Stephen is
an artist who creates
incredibly intricate
drawings of cityscapes.
- [Stephen] I love drawing tall buildings,
tall skyscrapers, skylines, street scenes.
- [Narrator] And he does
this entirely from memory.
When Stephen was three, he
was diagnosed as autistic.
He was completely mute and
lived entirely in his own world.
Early on, Stephen's teachers noticed
he loved to draw.
He had found his way
to connect with others.
Stephen has the ability
to look at a subject
once and then draw an
accurate and detailed
picture of it, including
panoramas of entire
cities based off just a quick look.
- I go up in the helicopter
and then memorize it.
And then after being on the helicopter,
and then straight back at the
hotel and then start to do draw.
- [Narrator] His
incredible talent launched
an artistic career that has
taken him around the world.
- [Stephen] Los Angeles;
Dubai; Houston, Texas;
and Tokyo in Japan.
- [Narrator] And that's
just to name a few.
- New York's my favorite,
Empire State Building,
Chrysler Building, and there are lots
of yellow New York taxicabs.
- [Narrator] And Stephen has no plans
of stopping anytime soon.
- [Stephen] If someone told
me, though, people like
me drawings, I feel good,
always be happy about it.
(electronic music)